if U.S lawmakers can't agree on funding
the government before 1201 am local time
on October 1st some federal Offices will
be forced to shut down this could affect
millions of Americans who may suddenly
find they can no longer visit a national
park attend a preschool and more if the
government does shut down you know these
agencies they they're furloughed or
they're not coming into the office or
anything like that and we really rely on
them
here's why they might close the U.S
government is funded annually through 12
spending bills passed in the House of
Representatives and the Senate the 12
pieces of legislation are typically
passed in one giant Bill known as
Omnibus legislation but this year some
opposed that I've got members who have
held us up since the summer not to be
able to bring our appropriation bills up
otherwise we'd probably have them all
done objection
House Republicans are instead in
Sidwell bill
visually an impossible task by October
1st these representatives are from the
party's right wing and they're using the
threat of a shutdown to force deep
long-term Cuts in government spending
the house has passed just one bill so
far the Senate none with Congress and
gridlock a partial government shutdown
appears imminent President Biden and his
team say they want to avoid a government
shutdown and are pushing Congress to
come to an agreement because of the harm
they fear will Ripple across every facet
of the U.S government our work would
clearly be affected
by this it would make it harder to do
everything that we do to try to advance
National Security so we urge congress
not to take this step all non-essential
federal agencies could close everything
from food safety inspections disaster
relief even inspections done by the
Environmental Protection Agency or EPA
but those receiving monthly checks from
the government known as Social Security
and Medicare would not be affected by a
partial shutdown what would be affected
is global faith in the U.S economy this
would be the fourth U.S government
shutdown in 10 years Kimberly halket Al
Jazeera the White House
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera